este 25 de noviembre Colombia ha salido
de la calle para conmemorar el día por
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres y es que Precisamente en
Colombia sufre una lacra que no cesa lo
que va de años según la fiscalía ha
habido más de 180 casos de feminicidios
algo que para las organizaciones
independientes y los observatorios
feministas apuntan a que han sido más de
500 las víctimas de femicidio en lo que
vaya año apuntando aún su registro y
precisamente nos encontramos con dos
familiares de víctimas de feminicidios
Camila Cuéntame un poco que sienten las
familiares de víctimas de feminicidio
sienten el respaldo del estado o están
qué está pasando con estas sentimos que
estamos revictimizadas en Colombia
porque no hay unas políticas públicas
que sean fuertes contra los feminicidios
Y nos sentimos que no somos apoyadas y
que este tema no está siendo
visibilizado en Colombia por eso estamos
acá luchando por las que ya no están en
mi caso por mi mamá que fue víctima de
feminicidio para visibilizar este tipo
de casos Nidia y usted me contaba que
precisamente reivindicar esta este
delito ha supuesto que usted sea
amenazada Además de que usted perdió a
su hija víctima de un feminicidio porque
está aquí hoy
Bueno yo sí quiero seguir en la lucha
para que nos sigan siendo vulnerados
nuestros derechos mi hija fue asesinada
en manos de amigos y el estado no le
importa a raíz de mi lucha precisamente
me amenazaron y el estado no hace nada
están esperando que pase algo y después
ya para qué
igual nada no hay una condena que nos
devuelva nuestra a nuestras amadas
Muchas gracias en Colombia en lo que va
de año la violencia intrafamiliar ha
aumentado en un 9% son víctimas no solo
las mujeres sino también las mujeres
trans Y es que en lo que va de año ha
habido más de 59 casos de
transfeminicidios por eso hoy aquí en
las calles están exigiendo el cese de
esta violencia y que este día se puede
en un solo día de impunidad y de
reivindicación sino que sea algo que se
conmemore todos los días y que sea una
lucha que lleve al cese de la violencia
contra las mujeres niñas adolescentes y
mujeres trans en el país